في غزه ومراسلنا هناك شامه زقوت هشام نحدث
معك اخر اذا التطورات وتحديدا حصيله
الضحايا من شهداء واصابات ايضا
سلام قبل الحديث عن
المجمل الشهداء والجرحى بدات الان فعليا
مراسم تشييع الشهداء من داخل ثلاجه
الشهداء في مجمع شفاء
هذه
الجبهه اهالي هؤلاء الشهداء
وستنطلق الى المسجد العمري الكبير
المالي عدد
هنا في مجمع شفاء الطبي وسيسيرون
شهيدا بينهم اربع اطفال واربع سيدات
ومخ
تلفا من الجرحى ما زالت حالتهم ما بين
حرجه وخطيره جراء هذه
المتزامنه والمتواصله التي
الاسرائيليه على
قطعه مخت
لفه اذن
الجتامين الان تبدا بالتحرك الى المسجد
العمري
وهناك ستتم عمليه
التشييع والتابين لهؤلاء الشهداء هؤلاء
القاده الكبار في سرايا القدس الجناح
العسكري لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي نحن نتحدث
عن قاده بارزين لهم مناصب موازنه
ومهمه في سرايا القدس الجناحه العسكري
لسرايا القدس اذا تحدثنا عن خليل البهتيني
فهو قائد في
الشماليه وهو اتهمته اسرائيل بانه مسؤول
بارز ومسؤول عن اطلاق صواريخ وتنفيذ
عمليات والتخطيط ايضا
لعمليات لضد الاحتلال الاسرائيلي واستهدفت
منزله وكانت اصلا اسرائيل قد وضعته على
دائره الاغتيالات هو وعدد من قضيه
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وكان هو ابرز هذه
القيادات ايضا نحن نتحدث عن جهات غنام
الذي سيشيع في مدينه رفح جنوب قطاع غزه
وجهاد غنام هو قائد باريس في سرايا القدس
وامين سر المجلس العسكري في السرايا وهو
مجاهد يمكن وصفه بانه قديم وتعرض لعده
محاولات اغتيال قصف منزله في حرب
2014 واستشهد عدد من اقاربه وهو من الرعيل
الاول
[موسيقى]
لصينيه يبلغ من العمر 62 عاما
وبدرت قدماه بعد استهداف من طائرات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي له خلال مشاركته في
عمليات قصف الهاون على مستوطنات الاحتلال
بدايه الانتفاضه
الانتخابات الاقصى
التشييع بدات
ستنطلق الى
ستكون هناك مسيره بسيطه في ستنطلق في
شوارع مدينه
ستتجه هذه المسيره الى
المسجد العمري الكبير
معنا ونحن اذا نشاهد معك هذه الصور مباشره
من امام مجمع الشفاء الطبي في غزه